sofía vergara posts the sexiest selfie  possibly ever we're all very very  excited the Modern Family star shared  this steamy shot to Instagram Thursday  wearing it nothing but some of  figure-hugging up black lacy a lingerie  oh and her makeup is smudged all over  the actress captioned the pic just  another day at the office  hashtag set life hashtag the Brits are  coming fYI that's the name of Sophia's  upcoming movie it's a jewelry heist  comedy good still we can't help but  wonder what Sophia's hubby Joe  Manganiello thinks about that  pic I don't know I'm always very special  with him so you must have been one of my  normal days